hello and welcome to project from a
through the Sanskrit words refer refers
to the powerful third eye of the Hindu
god Shiva praneetha is an ongoing
project at the ec department of carnegie
mellon university broad objectives aim
to research and create cost-effective
independence enhancing solutions to
benefit blind and visually impaired
people a recent develop solution
incorporates a smartphone with a
text-to-speech engine and a wireless UPC
barcode scanner this allows the user
discover individual products while
grocery shop already arms the UPC
barcode solution is comprised of several
working parts these include the Nokia
6620 smartphone around in symbian
seven-point oh and the Texas page
software talks the barcode a pencil UPC
reading device provides input to a C++
application using bluetooth wireless
connectivity once a product has been
scanned the application will check local
cache for a description of the property
in the case of a cache miss the
application will attempt to identify the
product by making a tcp request over
GPRS another input device being tested
is wireless RFID reader also
manufactured by bar about this continued
usage of commercial off-the-shelf
products helps to ensure we meet our
goal or cost-effective independent
solutions are the blind ever saw
Oh